- [Instructor] In the next
few videos, we're gonna do
a very high-level overview
of ancient history.
We're literally going to try
to cover 3,000 years of history
in a handful of videos.
And we're going to focus on
not all of the history in the world,
and it's worth noting that
there's going to be history
in North and South America
that we're not gonna talk about
in this video, history in
Africa or parts of Africa
that we're not going to
talk about in this video,
parts of Europe, parts of the Far East,
but we're gonna focus
mainly on the Middle East.
So, this yellow line, this is going to be
the historical timeline for ancient Egypt.
So, that is Egypt.
We're talking about that
area right over there.
This green timeline right over here,
you could view this as Judea.
We could also include,
we could include Judea,
which is where modern-day
Israel, Palestine.
If we're talking about Lebanon,
then we could include
Phoenicia right over there.
So, I'll just write Judea.
Judea.
That's a little hard to read.
This blue and red and
white line right over here,
this will be Mesopotamia.
So, this will be Mesopotamia.
We talk a little bit about
that in another video,
the area between or around the
Tigris and Euphrates River,
mainly in modern-day Iraq,
that region right over there.
So, if we say this is
Judea, this is Mesopotamia.
And we will also touch a
little bit later on Persia,
which is that area there.
The ancient Greece.
We're gonna talk a little bit
about Rome, about Carthage,
and a little bit about the Indus Valley,
the Indus Valley civilizations,
which is in now modern-day Pakistan.
So, with that geographic bearing,
and this is a line for, I'll
call this the Indus Valley.
Or Indus Valley, or I could say India.
And, obviously, India's much more
than just the Indus Valley.
And even this line over
here, that's China,
although I'm not gonna go much
into that into this video.
So, let's start about 5,000 years ago.
And there were already people
in all of the regions that I talk about,
but where I'm really highlighting
is where you start to have
significant empires develop.
And I'll start in Egypt,
where you have the Pharaoh,
you have King Menes.
He's able to unify Upper and Lower Egypt.
And it's a little counter-intuitive;
Upper Egypt is actually
south of Lower Egypt,
and that's because the Nile
River forms further South
and then it flows northward.
And so, he's able to unify
Upper and Lower Egypt,
Upper's off the map here,
into the Egyptian civilization
that we often associate
with ancient Egypt.
And it is a very, very, very
long-lived civilization.
And this is right at around the same time
you have folks living in
Mesopotamia, you have the Akkadians.
We're going into deep history now,
so we don't know exactly what was going on
in the Indus Valley,
but we believe that there
were people there as well,
and there were people
many, many other places.
But now, let's fast-forward.
We're gonna go about 500 years.
And we associate ancient
Egypt with the pyramids,
and, relatively speaking,
the pyramids were built
fairly early in the
history of ancient Egypt.
They were built about 2500 BCE,
or so we're talking about
4,500-4,600 years ago
was the time that,
especially the most famous,
the Great Pyramid of Giza was built.
But now, let's fast-forward even more.
And in this narrative
that I'm gonna talk about
in this video, I'm going to
introduce some characters
from the Old Testament.
And a lotta the stories
from the Old Testament,
they have bases in
history, but some of them,
the historical evidence isn't as clear.
But I'm gonna include it
because it's so much a
part of Judeo-Christian,
Islamic, Western, and
not just Western culture
that I think it gives us
an interesting bearing
and, frankly, a lotta the
stories from the Old Testament
are just really fascinating stories.
So now, let's fast-forward to 1700 BCE.
And even though that seems like
a very, very long time ago,
and it was, it's nice to get our bearings.
Because in 1700 BCE, and we're
gonna talk about Hammurabi,
who lived in, who ruled over
Babylon, the Babylonian Empire.
So, Hammurabi right over here in Babylon,
famous for the Code of Hammurabi.
He codified a series of laws.
We believe Abraham grew up at
around the same time in Ur.
And Abraham, we believe
that he was coincident
or maybe came a little bit after Hammurabi
because a lotta the Old Testament
seems to at least be inspired
by some of what we see
in Hammurabi's Code.
And it's worth noting that
even though this seems
like a long time ago,
around 1700 BCE, the time of Hammurabi,
and it turns a little white here
'cause this is where the Babylonians
become one of the dominant
empires in Mesopotamia,
even though it seems like a long time ago,
it's worth noting that
in the time of Hammurabi
and in the time of Abraham,
the pyramids were already close
to, what, 700-800 years old.
So, they already would've
viewed the pyramids
as a very, very old thing.
But if we go with roughly the year 1700
for about the time of Abraham,
he goes to what becomes Judea
and his tribe becomes established there
and then ends up, that's
where I have this line
going from Mesopotamia to Judea,
and we kinda see the
established Judea here.
And once again, they're
not the first people there.
You had the Canaanites,
you had the Phoenicians,
you had many other folks in this region,
but this is interesting because it relates
to the Old Testament that
many folks are familiar with.
And then you have the Old,
so this is around 1700.
Let me write this.
This is 1700 BCE.
And once again, I'll put approximately.
And then you go a few hundred years
and there isn't a lot of
historical basis here,
but based on the Old
Testament, the story of Joseph,
Joseph going to Egypt
and becoming the vizier
for the Pharaoh and
then his family coming,
Joseph, who is Abraham's grandson,
according to the Old Testament,
that story happens around,
and once again, this is not
established well historically
and I encourage you to look up
and see if you can find evidence yourself
of when folks think this
is, but the best evidence,
if this happened, the
best evidence I've seen
is it's around 1500
BCE, the story of Joseph
and the migration of the Jewish people,
or a significant chunk
of the Jewish people,
to Egypt, where they get enslaved.
And that enslavement is from 1500,
they get enslaved by the Pharaoh, 1500,
to approximately 1200 BCE.
And so, that story, you go all the way
from Abraham through Joseph,
this is in the Old Testament,
this happens in Genesis,
and then we get to the story of Moses,
where he sets his people
free, the story of Exodus
and the Jews are able
to go back to Jerusalem.
Moses leads them, parts the Red Sea,
according to the Old Testament,
and there established
the kingdom of Jerusalem
where you have the famous kings,
King Saul, then King
David, then King Solomon;
Solomon, who famous for
building the first temple.
And now, since I'm already
close to the 10-minute mark,
I'll leave you there,
because we've already covered
about 2,000 years of history (laughs)
in about eight minutes.
In the next video, we're
gonna go from about 1,000 BCE
to the Roman Empire
and the birth of Jesus.